it is July 3rd 2023 and you're watching
the code report in his latest 7D chess
move Elon surprised Twitter users with
some exciting new features first he
decreed a rate limit for everyone on the
platform non-blue checks get to look at
600 tweets per day while paying members
get to look it up to 6 000 tweets that
may sound harsh but this is just some
tough love from the Twitter King to help
us beat off our social media addictions
if you're having withdrawals though you
can always count on a programmer with an
anime profile image to save the day like
this person who developed a chrome
plugin that uses the old Twitter theme
and bypasses the rate limit the second
new feature is that Twitter shut off all
public access to the website So
currently you must be signed in to look
at Tweets in other words Twitter is
almost a full-blown paywall site now
officially these new features were
deployed on a Friday in a panic because
too many Bots and web scrapers were
accessing tweets with automated tools
web scraping is an absolutely despicable
practice and if you want to learn how to
do it at an industrial scale check out
this video on my second channel to add
insult to injury Twitter went down for a
while yesterday and it appears some bad
JavaScript code made it into production
that would call the API in an infant
Blue from the client side resulting in a
self-inflicted DDOS attack the thing is
though real men test in production I was
able to obtain exclusive access to this
garbage code and what we have is a
recursive async function that will catch
and fetch forever but Twitter's been
around for nearly 20 years at this point
so why is web scraping all of a sudden a
big problem well a couple months ago
Twitter shut down access to its free API
and made it way too expensive for any of
us peasant level developers to access
this move also inspired the Reddit CEO
to strap on a set of balls and take his
API pricing to the Moon to kill off
third-party apps despite a massive
failed protest the pricing went into
effect yesterday and third-party apps
like Apollo are officially dead let's
take a moment of silence for those we
lost
foreign
about this whole Twitter Fiasco is that
I find it somewhat hard to believe that
web scraping is the primary reason they
would Implement such drastic changes
especially because this would reduce
advertising Impressions which is still
by far its biggest source of Revenue if
we do a little more research we'll find
that Twitter had been refusing to pay
its Google Cloud bill at least until
recently Sundar had to hit up Elon via
SpaceX his other company that launches
Rockets into fake space which also does
business with gcp it's not the only Bill
that Twitter hasn't paid and was
recently evicted from its Boulder
Colorado offices over unpaid rent the
Google Cloud contract is a way bigger
deal though at hundreds of millions of
dollars per year and coincidentally
expired on June 30th it's pure
speculation whether these new features
are related to the Google Cloud contract
but like I've said many times before
once you get locked into a cloud
platform they have you by the balls if
you stop paying the bill you first get
bumped down to a rate limited tier and
then eventually the lights go out that
could explain why titter implemented a
rate limit because they're likely right
in the middle of migrating their
infrastructure to a Raspberry Pi which
are still pretty hard to come by another
theory going around is that Elon is
actually fighting in a battle against
agencies like the CIA and NSA who are
the ones behind all the scraping and
trying to use Twitter to create a death
star of censorship I don't know if
that's just Elon Fanboy fiction but I'm
still putting my money on him in his
upcoming death match against Zuck in the
Roman Coliseum he's got the body of a
mid-century refrigerator and I just
don't see any way five foot eight Zuck
will be able to overcome the size
differential but let me know whose
corner you're in in the comments no
matter the outcome though the important
thing is that we enjoy our bread and
circuses this has been the code report
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one